[Music]
bees are in trouble they're dying off at
alarming rates because of human
interference but our planet needs them
this man is using the data from b sounds
to help raise awareness and he does it
using experimental electronic music
in my lifetime half the number of bees
have disappeared
i wanted to draw attention to the plight
of bees through their sound
i use the name bioni as an alias it's
not my real name
welcome to my bee house
i
started recording bees in my hives about
20 years ago
and i always wear this vintage bee suit
because i want people to concentrate
just on my music
[Music]
all my music's based around the sounds
of bees it's the sound of the actual
bees inside the hives which i've taken
and processed into new sounds and it's
also the sound of honey where i pass an
electrical current through the honey
bioni uses homemade equipment to extract
data from the different sounds and
frequencies of the bees
the queen is a high-pitched sound
the workers is a medium pitch sound
and the drones are a lower pitch sound
i can extract samples from the
recordings and put them onto my
synthesizer and then play those live as
i perform
i travel all around the world get
invited to
music festivals which have an interest
in ecology as well
he hopes that enough people will be
moved by his music to consider their
impact on bee populations
[Music]
[Applause]
i think the sounds of bees connect to
people it's quite emotional so i thought
if people got interested in bees through
their sound and the technology and
education side they'd also become
interested in the eco side as well about
saving bees
[Music]